three people are reported to have been
killed in Iran following protests over
the death of a woman in police custody
22 year old Masa amini fell into a coma
and died following her arrest by the
country's morality police in Tehran last
week our Middle East correspondent
Alistair bunkel has this update
it's conflicting reports as to what
happened to this 22 year old girl she
was arrested by Iran's morality police
for incorrect wearing of her hijab her
head covering now when she died in
custody the police released CCTV that
they claim shows that she died of
natural causes perhaps a heart condition
her family say that is not the case that
she was Fit and Well she would have had
no signs whatsoever to have died under
those circumstances and there are
reports that some scans done on her head
post-mortem show fractures to the skull
and hemorrhaging on on her head which
would Point towards this accusation that
she was beaten whilst in Iranian police
custody the consequence of it has now
been a number of days of protests across
Iran mainly focused in the Kurdish west
of the country because she was Kurdish
but also there have been protests on the
streets of the capital Tehran now there
are reports we haven't yet verified them
yet and they haven't been verified
independently internationally that five
protesters were killed by Iranian police
when they opened fire on them but what
it all points towards is an increasingly
escalating situation certainly between
the Kurdish minority in Iran and the
government but more so between the
Iranian population and the morality
police who are not liked within Iran
the Iranian president ibrahimovici has
traveled to New York he's landed in New
York for the United Nations General
Assembly he will address the general
assembly later on today and he will be
hoping that the protests will have died
down and Gone Away by that stage at the
moment though it doesn't look like
that's going to be the case